julie now is clean shaven for a while
yeah growing up he's
not looking like he's a rabbi anymore
big giant mandy
tank and beard but now he's uh groomed
nicely and i prefer it actually i like
it you look like aqualung before you
know jethro tull's album
but my mom called me and yelled at me
and i went and got a haircut in the
shade
look at julie's haircut
used to look like the guy on the cover
of aqua lung
he still has lots of chest hair though
all right enough of that your wife never
complained
no my wife actually liked it which is
the only reason it stuck around
oh my mom is this what you look like on
the facebook
that i see
she said you look like a terrorist and
hasidum
she says you need to shave now why do
you listen to your mother you're a grown
man you got your own job you got your
own family i mean
why does your mother have that power
over you i don't know man it was weird
because i was so
into this experiment of just seeing what
the hell is going to happen
with with the hair on my head and my
face and then she just called me up and
was like legit
people are calling from israel asking if
you are homeless
like she was really mad when you had the
beard
and everything you kind of look like a
more edgy kind of comic i'll be honest
with you yeah you know for your career i
think it might have given you a look i
don't know i could do comics taxes
right maybe you were lenny bruce's
accountant many years ago financial
planner
i like that julie's mom yelled at him
and he shaved the beard off
immediately that's weird like it's
unbelievable the power mothers have
how old is julie looking for his mom's
approval aren't you like when you're
50s how old are you 45 yeah i mean jesus
yeah
ridiculous yeah i mean honestly
some people thought you look like a
funny fiddler on the roof
kind of guy but but i love the market
for that
yeah sure i don't know many comics that
look like fiddler on the roof and like
you could come out and go
you got music and everything now you can
walk out too all day long
if i was a verti man ivey
bear wouldn't have to work hard
you got the first 15 minutes of your act